[MUSIC PLAYING]
ROMAN NURIK: Hello, and welcome
to Android Design in
Action, the third episode
of this awesome show.
I'm Roman Nurik, your host.
I'm broadcasting live
from New York City.
And we're joined to my right
by Nick Butcher, coming in
live from London.
NICK BUTCHER: Hello.
And welcome back from
your holiday, Roman.
I hope you enjoyed the shore.
ROMAN NURIK: Thank you.
Thank you, Nick.
It was quite an awesome
holiday.
We actually went to San
Diego, which was nice.
And I caught up on the
show that you and
Adam did last week.
It was quite good.
Very good job.
NICK BUTCHER: Thank you.
ROMAN NURIK: So those of you
that this is I guess your
first time watching, Android
Design in Action is a show
where we basically look at some
of the apps that were
previously reviewed in the
Friday App Clinic broadcast
from Mountain View.
And we take a look at them in
more detail visually, kind of
more from a design standpoint.
And we also re-imagine
them, give them a
makeover if you will.
So today, we're going to look
at a few camera apps,
specifically Camera Zoom
FX and Glimmr.
So let's just get right into
it and start with our first
app, Camera Zoom FX.
So Camera Zoom FX is basically
a camera replacement that
gives you tons and tons of
additional features.
It gives you special effects,
things like overlays, things
like borders, hipster filters.
If you can see here, there's
that FX button.
And it also gives you a bunch
of customizable settings for
your camera like zoom and flash
and things like that.
It also lets you customize the
type of camera you use.
So you can use--
or the type of shutter,
I guess.
You could use a single shot.
You could use kind
of a time lapse.
You could use an interval or a
countdown, things like that.
So we had a couple of comments
on this app, a couple of
visual comments.
And I'll start it.
And Nick will jump in as well.
I guess the first couple of
comments that I had visually
are basically there's a lot
of controls on the screen.
And you can see that there's
some controls on the left and
some controls on the right.
And there doesn't seem to be a
strong order or purpose for
the placement of
these controls.
The other thing you can't really
see here, but a lot of
the assets were blurry.
And they weren't optimized
for XHDPI devices.
And this is something that
we see pretty often.
And it's something that's very
easy to fix normally.
And there's really also a
mixed bag of styling.
There's these faux-3D
skeuomorphic
elements on the right.
There's these gradient custom 3D
elements on the top right.
And then on the left, you
have flatter icons.
So the styling was really
interspersed.
There's different kinds
of styles throughout.
So that was one thing that we
wanted to look into changing.
And you'll see in the next
couple of screens as we review
those that there are also
different styles for the
different pop-ups and dialogs
that come up.
Also, you'll notice
that there's the--
actually, Nick, do you want to
say anything about these three
little dots on the top right?
NICK BUTCHER: The
button of shame.
ROMAN NURIK: The button
of shame.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, so this is
for developers who haven't yet
optimized their application to
run on devices with software
navigation keys.
And so you get this
emulated button.
And it's kind of ugly, and
kind of hard to hit, and
doesn't really offer the best
experience for your users.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
And any other thoughts on
Camera Zoom FX, Nick, or
should we jump into
the redesign?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, I think the
two major things for me
was the inconsistent styling,
which wasn't really the
Android Holo type theme that
you would expect perhaps,
coupled with just some clarity
about what the iconography
meant and how to actually
use the app.
We found that if you just look
at the screen, it isn't too
intuitive how to go about it.
So let's see what
we do with it.
ROMAN NURIK: OK.
So let's look at the redesign.
And you can see here that most
of the placement, I guess, the
general placement, having
controls on the left and the
right of the screen, we kept.
But we did do a couple
things differently.
And let me talk through all
those individual points.
So the first thing is that we
wanted to simplify the mental
model for users.
We basically put camera
and camera-related
settings on the right.
So all on the right, you see
things like focus, change the
camera from front to
back, take a photo,
settings, and then zoom.
And then on the left,
we just put effects.
So everything that is kind of
the special sauce of this app,
the effects and the cool things
you can do to your
photos, we put on the left.
So it simplifies the
model for users.
The other thing that we did, and
you'll see this later on,
is that we combined the settings
here, this shutter
type setting, with other camera
settings that were, I
think, under this button.
We combined that into a single
affordance here.
And we'll see an example
of that in a bit.
The other thing I wanted to
point out is that we made the
actual shutter button larger.
And this is actually coming
from feedback that Ian
mentioned in the App
Clinic last week.
Basically, if you place
something very close to a
system button like the Home
button, users are very likely
to hit that button
accidentally.
And so here, what we did was
we made the camera button
larger both horizontally and
vertically so the tap target
is much more obvious.
We also put a lights out mode
so that you hide the Home
button, the Back button, and the
Recent button so that it
doesn't crowd your vision.
And another thing I'll mention
is that we used more standard
iconography throughout,
and a standard style.
We used a Holo dark style on a
semi-transparent action bar.
So you'll see here that
a lot of these icons
are more common icons.
I do want to point out that
some of these icons are
actually from androidicons.com
by Guenther Beyer.
And we mentioned Guenther's
work on the first
episode of the show.
So a lot of these icons are
from there as well.
So thanks, Guenther.
The last thing I want to mention
is I guess about--
actually, there's
a caveat here.
You'll notice that there's these
not really action bars.
There are these control bars on
the left and the right And
they're semi-transparent.
Now, if you've developed a
camera app before, you may
think, oh, it's not always
the case that I can get a
full-screen picture,
a full-screen view.
So in those cases when you don't
have a full-screen view,
there are a couple of options.
You can do letter boxing.
You can also choose to make
either the left or the right
control bar fully black instead
of semi-transparent.
And there's lots of other
options that you could do.
And I think in a very fancy
case, you could even start
mirroring the edges of the
screen or mirroring the edges
of the preview around the
borders, things like that.
OK, so that's the design
at a glance.
Nick, do you have any
comments on the
difference between the two?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, I
instantly loved the
improvements on the shutter
button because you've managed
to marry the visual identity
of the application.
And so if you go to this
application's listing on the
Play Store, it has these
colorful elements, which
you've picked out in
the shutter button
really, really nicely.
And I'm also a big fan of using
the overlay style, the
semi-transparent button bars as
well because it makes you
feel like the picture
is getting the whole
window, which is--
it's a camera app.
This is what it's all about,
taking photos.
So I love the way that we've
extended that photo to fill
the edges where possible.
So that's two of my
favorite elements.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, and like I
mentioned before, one of the
hardest things is getting
a photo to fill.
I actually don't know about Ice
Cream Sandwich or Jelly
Bean, if we have this.
But one option is, if you can,
maybe even crop the image that
you don't see the top
and the bottom.
There's lots of different
options.
But that's just, as somebody
that's worked on a camera
before, it's definitely
something that comes up.
It is difficult to do.
But if you can do it, your app
can look really great.
So let's move on to
the next screen.
In this next screen, you'll
notice that we moved some of
these deeper, nested
effects pop-ups.
Again, we moved the effects from
the right to the left to
simplify the model for users.
We moved this panel
to the left.
And so when you select this
Edit control, you see
basically this secondary set
of controls to its right.
And in the original app, there's
actually a third set.
So you could imagine having
three sets here.
And at that point, you're really
thinking more about the
controls and finding the thing
you want than the photo.
So maybe potentially overlaying
on top of the
photo may be OK.
But we didn't go too much in
depth there because at that
point, it's really up to
the developer what
they want to do.
And I just want to, in the
interest of time, switch over
to this screen.
And this is where you basically
select a shutter type.
So you can go from a normal
to a timer to--
I actually don't know what
a collage does--
stable shot.
Lots of different shutter
types, and
that's really awesome.
This is a pretty unique feature
that it has all these
different types.
But again, we decided to move
that into settings.
So basically, you touch
Settings, and then, touch
Normal Shutter Type and select
which one you want.
You could probably even improve
that flow faster by
having a special widget at
the top, maybe one that
horizontally scrolls.
But that's just one way to
do things like that.
And the reason we did this was
to really just simplify,
again, really simplify this
fairly complex app so that any
types of settings related to
camera go into one place.
Nick, any parting thoughts
for Cameras Zoom FX?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, I love what
you've done with this.
I think it's a very powerful app
that lets you do a lot of
different things with images.
But having its custom UI means
it's quite hard to take in all
those different options
that you can do.
So I think using things like the
standard design language,
the Holo icons and standard
controls like spinners, really
makes it much quicker to pause
and understand what's going on
in the app and really get down
to the functionality of what
you want to use.
ROMAN NURIK: Yep.
OK, so let's move on
to the next app.
And the next app is Glimmr.
So I'll let Nick go ahead
and jump into
his thoughts on Glimmr.
ROMAN NURIK: So basically, the
app Glimmr is an application
for letting you access
photos on Flickr, the
photo-sharing website.
It's quite a new app
on the market.
And some people might be
surprised to see us addressing
it on Android Design in Action
because, overall, I actually
really like it.
It's a really nice app.
It's using a lot of the Holo
design language, things like
horizontal swiping and
so on are present.
But as with any Android design
project, there's one aspect
which you have to consider,
which I don't think they've
really addressed too well, and
that is designing for all
different device varieties
out there.
So I've actually taken this from
a different standpoint
than usual.
And we've run this on a 10-inch
device on a tablet and
looked at how it comes out and
then decided to apply more
Android design philosophy on how
we could improve things.
So moving to the third screen
here, if you can make it out,
this is the first thing you're
presented with when the user
installs the application.
It's a log-on screen.
It's quite sparse, minimally,
extremely sparse.
It just says, "Welcome to
Glimmr," and a Log-On button.
And I think this is a real
missed opportunity.
When a user installs your
application, they don't always
know exactly what it does
or how high quality is.
And you've got a very
short amount of
time to impress them.
In fact, if the first thing
you show them is a sparse
screen with a button forcing
them to log in, it's almost
like you're throwing your
hand upward and
showing a stop sign.
And I'm sure there'll be a drop
off here where a number
of users just don't even press
it there and carry on, which
would be a shame, because
they'll be missing out on a
great application.
So what we've done
here is we--
if you want to go
to the redesign.
ROMAN NURIK: Yup.
NICK BUTCHER: We've made content
come to the fore and
offered a different experience
when you load in.
So Flickr is about
photos, right?
It's all about sharing photos.
So the first thing you see when
you launch this app, in
my opinion, should be some
rich, rich imagery.
Flickr exposes a feed called
interestingness, which shows
some great imagery.
So what we've done here
is we've pulled out
some images from that.
And this is the first
thing you now see.
So instantly, it's engaging.
It speaks to what this
app is all about.
It's all about beautiful
photographs.
And what's more, it offers some
functionality now without
logging in.
So there's a strong call to
action there to log in today
with your Flickr account.
But alternatively, you've got a
little hint there saying you
can touch a photo.
And this'll take you right into
the core of the app, say,
viewing photos and seeing
comments on the photos.
So straight away, we're
not logging in.
We're exposing more content
to the users.
And also, we hope you'll agree
it looks a little bit better
at taking advantage of the
extra screen real estate
available to you on this
larger device.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
The one thing I want to point
out here, Nick, is Nick did
the design for this app.
And one of the things that
instantly makes your app look
better-- and we've done this in
past episodes of the show--
is just using different weights
of Roboto, different
fonts in that family.
So in this case, Nick, you've
used Roboto thin, is it?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, Roboto
Thin and then Regular.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, so using
Roboto Thin is--
I just want to point out,
it's really great for
really large type.
So if you have something like
an initial screen that says
"Welcome," or you want to
display a nice, big piece of
text, especially on a tablet
for like 48, even 64, 72
scale-independent pixel sizes,
Roboto Thin is really awesome.
NICK BUTCHER: Cool.
ROMAN NURIK: So let's move
on to the next screen.
And this is the screen where--
actually, Nick, you want
to talk about it?
It's the Sets screen.
Is that right?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
So once you get into the app,
once you've logged in with
your Flickr account, it offers
different views on your data.
So you can see your photos,
your sets, which is
collections of your photos,
folders, if you will, as well
as seeing groups and things
from your contacts.
So I've pulled out the Sets
screen here because, as you
can see, on the tablet, you
get these horizontal,
full-width images which just
really don't scale up too well
to a larger device.
So we've look at that.
And we've applied a different
kind of layout to really take
advantage of the real estate
available to you.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, so I've
just moved over to the
redesign screen.
I just want to also point out
regarding those full-width
widgets, basically any time you
have anything that's full
width on a tablet,
you have to think
twice about it, basically.
Because that's just a lot of
space, not even for lines of
text, but even photos.
Photos are very, very rich.
But when you have such an
awkward aspect ratio, like
fixed height in a full-width
row, you don't really get as
much out of it.
So yeah, Nick, do you want to
talk about the redesign?
NICK BUTCHER: Yes.
There's a few things
we've done here.
Firstly, we've switched over to
a dark theme as well, as we
showed on the log-on screen.
The thinking here is really
that, as we said before, we
want this to be all about the
photos, all about the imagery.
And having a darker background
really lets those images stand
out, really makes them pop.
So that's the reasoning for
switching over to the fully
dark rather than the light theme
or the dark action bars
as we saw before.
I've also moved away from the
horizontal swiping tabs, the
swipey tabs, because that very
long gesture on a tablet
device is a bit hard.
It isn't as intuitive
like switching
between pages of content.
And by pulling the tabs out
right into the action bar
where we have more space now
in this size, it gives you
instant access to switch between
these four major views
of your data.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: So the other thing
we've obviously done
there is we've gone to a grid
view to make better use of the
real estate and switched
it up from vertical
to horizontal scrolling.
So as you can see, the images
are going off to the right, so
you can scroll horizontally
and see more.
This screen's quite heavy, I
guess, influenced by the
standard Android gallery and
applications like Google+.
But we really hope we've
captured the spirit of Flickr
and married it with a really
rich viewing environment.
Some of the minor details that
you'll want to call out as
well is we de-emphasized some
of the visual information.
I found using the Glimmr
application that there was a
lot of information jumping out
at you, competing for my
attention from the photos.
So, for example, if you look at
the visual treatment of an
individual set here, like a
folder, we've made it 90%
almost about the picture.
And then there's a very
small callout saying
the name of the set.
And then less important,
secondary importance, we
de-emphasized the number
of photos in the set.
So we've used this relative size
and weight of text and
color to show the relative
importance of
the information there.
So I think this really makes
the photos stand out.
And then, if you really want to
know how many photos, it's
easily accessible.
But it doesn't compete
for your attention.
ROMAN NURIK: Two things I just
want to call out specifically
that I like about the changes
here, Nick, is just in terms
of padding and font treatment
or text treatment, you've
given the text, like
in this case Waves.
That's the title of the set.
You've given it slightly more
padding around the top,
bottom, and especially
the left.
And using either 4, 8, or
16 DPS of padding is
usually a good idea.
And I think that just helps
clean it up a bit.
In the current version of the
app, you'll notice that these
text labels-- and it's
very hard to see.
I apologize for that.
But these text labels, they're
scrunched over to the side and
squeezed by the top and
bottom borders of that
semi-transparent black box.
So giving it some more spacing
just helps bring it out ever
so slightly so that it's
a little more legible.
So let's look at the
last screen.
And this is the photo
detail screen.
Basically, when you
touch a photo, you
jump into this screen.
And there, it's basically a
full-screen photo and gives
you a couple of actions
at the top.
Nick, do you want to jump
into your analysis?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
You can probably skip on to
the next slide as well.
It's quite a simple
screen, really.
It's showing you a photo.
But there's a few things which
I wanted to change about the
screen, really.
Firstly, I changed over to using
an overlay action bar.
I hope it comes out in
the screenshot here.
So that's basically, I wanted
the screen to be
all about the picture.
I didn't want to border
at the top.
I wanted it to feel like
the photo was the
most important thing.
If you've used the application
as well, you can tap on the
main picture, and it'll
hide the action bar.
But it actually has a slightly
jarring animation where it
readjusts the size
of the image just
doing a layout pass.
And so using an overlay
action bar will negate
that issue as well.
The other thing is if you look
at the title of the photo,
it's kind of burned onto
the photo in the image.
Even if you go into the viewing
mode where you hide
the action bar, this title is
still going to hide the image.
So I've changed that and removed
the Glimmr name from
the action bar.
Because I think by this point,
you're using the app, you've
got the icon.
You know which application
you're in.
And just replaced the title with
the photo title there.
ROMAN NURIK: I think providing
that sense of place of where
you are, that's really what that
part of the action bar is
for, to tell you not only where
you can go and what you
can do, but where you are.
And so the action bar does
have a built-in title and
subtitle feature.
But in this case, Nick has
chosen to use a custom title
area that highlights that it's
a certain photo by the author
of the photo.
So let's move on.
Sorry, go on.
NICK BUTCHER: The only last
minor thing is I cleaned up
the iconography in the
action bar as well.
I feel like the functions
it's offering here, like
favoriting, sharing, is all
quite common iconography.
So I felt like it cleaned it
up having it as just icon
rather than icon and text
because you still have the
long press to get a tool tip
as well if you don't quite
understand what's going on.
But I just felt like it removed
all those distractions
away from the photo and
just simplified it.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, absolutely.
So let's look at the other
facet of this screen--
comments.
Do you want to talk
about that, Nick?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
Lastly, tapping on the comments
button or the
information button lets these
pop-ups which overlay the
photo obscuring it.
And I decided just
to give that a
little bit of a treatment.
I wanted to carry on
that theme that
content is king here.
It's all about the photograph.
So I went for an overlay
style again.
So I hope it comes out.
This is supposed to be a
semi-transparent pop-up box
that comes up.
And it's almost like
a toggle mode.
So you can see here when you hit
the comment button, this
panel will pop up.
And the idea here is
that will stay up.
So as you keep on horizontally
swiping to the next photos in
the set, that'll stay up, and
it'll just switch over.
Similarly, if you hit the Info
icon next to it, the idea is
it'll occupy the same space.
You could have the fun animation
of it, perhaps
rotating around, showing
you some
information about the photo.
And what we've done here is I
feel like having this overlay
information rather than that
obscuring pop-up, it really
takes better advantage of the
screen real estate available
on the tablet because you can
still see a large amount of
the image, which is what this
is all about, and then get
your comments experience
as well.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, awesome.
I especially like just
the treatment of
comments and text.
So basically, within the
comment, you have the author,
the comment author.
And there's lots of different
things you can do to make text
seem clickable or touchable
or interactive.
Basically, having it stand out,
giving it some color is
one sign, one indication.
But another thing you can do is
you could potentially use
underlines.
You could also just have, if you
choose, instead of having
the quick contacts, you can have
the profile icon actually
jump you there as well if you
decide that quick contacts
isn't for you.
NICK BUTCHER: If the author's
watching, this is also a
subtle hint that this
application, it already in the
background checks
for new photos
from your Flickr friends.
I've love for them to implement
a contact sync
adapter so that it joins up
between contacts and the
Flickr profile so that you can
use these quick contact badges
to quickly pivot from your other
applications into their
Flickr profile and so
on and so forth.
I love it when applications
integrate like that.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, basically any
time you have any sort of
social app, you should do
things like contacts
integration.
You should do things like social
stream API integration.
That really helps you
integrate even
further into the OS.
So let's move on from the
redesign of Glimmr to a new
section of Android Design in
Action, Android Design News.
And you guys did cover
this last week.
But we do want to help promote
some of the awesome work
that's been done in
the community.
And so this is a section that
we're hoping to do potentially
every week for the show.
And so let's start with
Android Design News.
And the first bit of news--
actually, Nick, do you want
to start with the
first bit of news?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, so I just
wanted to highlight an
excellent library of assets
which Cyril Motier of Green
Droid fame has opened sourced
to the community.
He's made some map markers for
making map pins, which are
very true in nature to
Google Maps style.
So these don't actually ship
with our Maps SDK, so these
are some great assets to getting
you bootstrapped and
customizing from there.
So thanks very much, Cyril,
for sharing these.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, absolutely,
thank you, Cyril.
The next one is from
Smashing Magazine.
And Smashing Magazine, for those
of you who aren't aware,
it's a magazine that's dedicated
to teaching the
world basically about different
aspects of design
and also implementation.
So if you're a web developer or
an Android developer or web
designer or an Android designer,
the Smashing
Magazine is a great
blog to follow.
They often highlight some of the
best stuff that's going on
in the industry.
In this case, what they've done
is they've highlighted
some mobile sketching
templates.
And they've actually released
mobile sketching templates for
Android, iOS, Windows.
I believe it's also
tablet and phone.
So if you're interested in doing
some sort of real-world
sketching with real pen or real
paper, pencil and paper,
then this is definitely
something you should go ahead
and download.
NICK BUTCHER: That's what I
used when I was doing the
sketches of Glimmr.
ROMAN NURIK: Nice, awesome.
Next is a similar kit from
Taylor Ling, who's one of the
awesome community folks that's
creating free, downloadable
assets for the rest of us.
It's a GUI sketching kit,
basically, very similar to the
previous kit.
But it's from Taylor.
And thoughts, Nick?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, I
think this is nice.
I found the photo in Smashing
Magazine maybe slightly
heavyweight.
And I found myself--
it was clearer using Taylor's
ones there.
They're not quite so heavy.
So your sketch actually stands
out over the frame, rather
than the Smashing one.
So take a look at them
both and see which
ones work for you.
ROMAN NURIK: Awesome, OK.
In other news, Android
Niceties--
is that how you pronounce
it, niceties?
I think it's niceties.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
ROMAN NURIK: So Android
Niceties, which is a blog, I
guess a Tumblr, blog, slash--
it's a media outlet,
I suppose--
that highlights awesome design
work in the world of Android,
celebrates its first birthday.
I think this blog highlights
some of the most awesome stuff
that's coming out of
the community.
You should all try to follow
it if you're interested in
seeing examples of some of
this stuff in action.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
Happy Birthday, Haberdash.
I'm probably murdering
their name.
It's probably easier to say
your name on Twitter.
So keep up the good work.
We love you, Rob.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, absolutely.
And I think this is lastly.
Yeah, lastly, Nick, do you want
to talk about Marie's
awesome redesign
of Rich's app?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
I think inspired by that some
of the comments from the App
Clinic and some of Roman's
redesigns from last week,
Marie has joined in the spirit
of the redesign movement and
has applied the Holo treatments
to the Ultimate
Stopwatch application by our
colleague Rich Hyndman.
So she shared all the assets
and everything.
So it's a great example of
taking a before and after
shot, like we've done.
So do check it out
at the link.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, I especially
love the work that
she's done with taking something
like a stopwatch and
making it tablet friendly.
One of the things that folks
sometimes have trouble with is
imagining, is my app really
useful on a tablet?
Does it make any sense
on a tablet?
And in general, the answer is
yes, because it's just--
when a user has both a tablet
and a phone, they'll expect
that when they jump to their
tablet, the version of the
Google Play Store on their
device that they see on a
tablet is basically going
to be the same
thing on the phone.
So if they happen to love your
app on the phone and it's just
not available on a tablet, or it
doesn't look very good, or
it's not really optimized for
a tablet, they're going to
think twice about using
your app next time.
They may use a competitor's
app on a tablet.
So in this case, Marie's just
taken a step in taking
something that really is
more like a square
thing, like a stopwatch.
A clock is really
a square thing.
What do you put on
the sides of it?
There's a lot of white space.
And she's taken that and merged
different parts of the
phone app into a single screen
so that you have a dashboard
of your different stopwatches.
NICK BUTCHER: She also is
thoroughly aware of the
Fragments APIs.
It's a great way of showing
how to do designs for the
Fragment way of thinking
as well.
So check it out.
ROMAN NURIK: OK, so that's all
we have for the show today.
Tune in next week where we will
cover, I believe, travel
planning apps.
We'll have to see what the
guys in the App Clinic go
through, which apps
they review.
So we'll take a crack at some
of those and review them, or
actually redesign some of the
screens from those apps.
So thanks for tuning in.
As always, I'm Roman Nurik.
And with me here today was
Nick Butcher from London.
And thanks, and hope to
see you next week.
NICK BUTCHER: Bye!
[MUSIC PLAYING]